تل ابيب تعلنها لا وقفه لاطلاق النار
وسنستمر بضربات العسكريه غارات كثيفه
اشتباكات عنيفه متواصله معارك محتدمه مئات
القتلى في قصف على مستشفى واحد في غزه
قياده اسرائيليه عسكريه تصرح نحن كنا
السبب في الفشل امام هجوم طوفان الاقصى
المانيا تحدد موعد الهجوم البري
الاسرائيلي على غزه فيما المستشار
الالماني يطلق تحذيرا شديد لايران ولبنان
معبر رفح المصري يعج بالمساعدات والقاهره
تتجه لتوسع الاتحاد الاوروبي يعقد اجتماعا
طارئا تقرير امريكي ارسلنا حاملتي
الطائرات لردع المقاومه اللبنانيه ما الذي
يجري فرنسا تنعق لها خلال الحرب
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه بوتين وشي جيب
بينغ على طاوله واحده ما الهدف وحاملات
الصواريخ الروسيه الاستراتيجيه تحلق فوق
بحر اليابان
يوم
دامن الحرب تحتدم تدخل نفقا مظلما الضربات
تتوالى ضجيج القصف يدوي في الارجاء ولا
امل في هدنه قريبه هنا المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي يصرح انه لا يوجد وقف اطلاق
نار في قطاع غزه مؤكدا الاستمرار في توجيه
الضربات العسكريه على القطاع وضرب مئات
الاهداف واكد ان الجيش يستعد للمرحله
التاليه التي قد تكون شيئا مختلفا عن
الهجوم البري على حد قوله اليكم المصدر
وسط هذا التصعيد اعلن المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه لا يوجد وقف اطلاق نار في
قطاع غزه مؤكد الاستمرار في توجيه الضربات
العسكريه على القطاع وضرب مئات الاهداف
لحركه حماس وقتل مسؤولين عن هجوم السابع
من اكتوبر ليعود متحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي
ويؤكد ان قوات الجيش تستعد لتنفيذ مجموعه
واسعه من الخطط الهجوميه بعد عده ايام من
القتال والانتهاء من تجنيد الاحتياط لمئات
الالاف من الجنود في الميدان حصل ما لم
يكن في الحسبان وبعد ان قصفت اسرائيل
مستشفى المعمداني في وسط مدينه غزه الذي
يضم مئات المرضى والجرحى والنازحين اعلنت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه سقوط اكثر من 800
بين قتيل وجريح في مشهد وصفه مسؤولون
فلسطينيون ووسائل اعلام بجريمه حرب اليكم
المصدر وفي تطور لافت قصفت اسرائيل مستشفى
الاهل المعمداني في وسط القطاع وافاد
المراسل الحدث بان اكثر من 800 شخص سقطوا
بين قتيل وجريح جراء القصف الذي استهدف
المستشفى بشكل مباشر وكان من المقرر ان
يستضيف ملك الاردن عبد الله الثاني
الرؤساء الامريكيه والمصري والفلسطيني
لعقد قمه رباعيه في العاصمه عمان لكن وزير
الخارجيه الاردني اعلن الغاء القمه لاحقا
بعد اليوم المروع الذي شهدته غزه فيما كان
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن شن
عشرات الغارات الجويه على حي الزيتون
وشمال رفح وجباليا وخان يونس وذلك
لاستهداف مقرات قياده لنشطاء عسكريين وشقق
اختباء لنشطاء من المقاومه كل هذه الهجمات
وتلك الخسائر تاتي قبل الاعلان عن الهجوم
البري حيث قالت مجله درش بجل الالمانيه ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد يبدا هجومه البري على
قطاع غزه بعد زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن الى اسرائيل لان الضوء الاخضر
الامريكي لن ياتي الا بعد مغادره بايدن
لاسرائيل المقاومه من جانبها كانت قد
اعلنت انها وجهت ضربات صاروخيه متتاليه
كبيره على تل ابيب وشون لتسيون وعسقلان
عدد من المناطق في اسرائيل كما اعلنت عن
قصف تجمع للجنود الاسرائيليين قرب مفك عيم
برشقه صاروخيه بينما شهد قطاع غزه هجوما
ضخما وعنيفا من قبل طائرات الجيش
الاسرائيلي تركز على مناطق شمال وشرق
القطاع مخلفا مئات القتلى والجرحى حيث
تعرضت مدينه رفح جنوبي القطاع الى هجوم هو
الاكبر منذ بدء الحرب وتجاوز عدد القتلى
فيها 107 واصابه عدد كبير في حصيله غير
نهائيه وقابله للزياده في كل لحظه بحسب
وكاله وفا الفلسطينيه خلال ذلك اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيا ان 21 مواطنا
فرنسيا قتلوا في حرب اسرائيل وفلسطين منذ
بدء الم معارك وبسبب التصيد في قطاع غزه
قرر المجلس الاوروبي عقد اجتماع طارئ لبحث
التداعيات المحتمله التي قد تكون خطيره
على القاره الاوروبيه من جراء هذه الازمه
في فلسطين ها هو المصدر يتحدث يعقد قاده
الاتحاد الاوروبي اجتماعا يهدف الى
التوافق على نهج موحد تجاه التصعيد في
قطاع غزه وفي الاجتماع الطارئ سيبحث
المجلس الاوروبي ايضا التداعيات المحتمله
التي قد تكون خطيره على القاره الاوروبيه
جراء هذه الازمه في ظل هذه الخسائر ومع
عداد الضحايا الذي لا يتوقف حمل رئيس جهزي
الشباك رونين بار وشعبه الاستخبارات
العسكريه امان هارون حليفا نفسيهما
المسؤوليه الكامله عن الفشل الاستخباراتي
الذي وقع في السابع من اكتوبر الجاري في
هجوم طوفان الاقصى وقال حليفه في رساله
اعتذار رسميه لقد فشلنا في مهمتنا وانا
اتحمل المسؤوليه الكامله عن هذا الفشل
المعارك تشتد في كل مكان على الحدود
اللبنانيه اعلن الصليب الاحمر اللبناني ان
اربعا من فرقه توجهت الى منطقه علم الشعب
جنوبي البلاد لنقل جثث اربع ضحايا جراء
القصف الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف البلده
القصف الاسرائيلي كان قد استهدف ايضا
بلدات عيت الشعب وميش وع ترون ردا على
اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدروع من هناك على هدف
للجيش الاسرائيلي هذا واعلنت المقاومه
اللبنانيه استهداف مواقع واليات اسرائيليه
عديده مؤكده تحقيق اصابات في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي بين قتيل وجريح في حين اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي التصدي لمسيره اخترقت
الاجواء قادمه من جنوب لبنان فيما كانت
الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه طلبت من سكان
مستوطنه كريات شموني الدخول الى الملاجئ
خشه سقوط صواريخ في المدينه مع دوي بصافره
الانذار ليوجه الغرب بوصلتهم نحو ايران
ولبنان حيث حذر المستشار الالماني اولف
شولز طهران وبيروت من التدخل في الصراع
الدائر في غزه وذلك خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع
العاهل الاردني فيما اعتبرت نيويورك تايمز
ان الامين العام للمقاومه اللبنانيه ورئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا يريدان حربا شامله
وان وصول حاملتي طائرات امريكيتين منع
المقاومه من الهجوم على اسرائيل وقال
مسؤولون امريكيون ان وصول الحملتين والسفن
المرافقه لهما يردع مقاومه لبنان عن
مهاجمه اسرائيل في الوقت الراهن لنعد الى
فلسطين حيث افاد مصدر امني مصري بان العمل
جار على توسيع بوابه معبر رفح بين مصر
وقطاع غزه حتى تتمكن الشاحنات من الدخول
الى الطريق الدولي المؤدي الى معبر كرم
ابو سالم هذا ونشر رئيس مؤسسه صناع الخير
للتنميه الخيريه صحفيون مصريون مشاهد تحرك
قوافل المساعدات لغزه من مدينه العريش
المصريه في سيناء نح ومعبر رفح الحدودي
بين مصر وقطاع غزه بينما جددت زوجه رئيس
وزراء اسكتلندا ناديه النقله نداءاته
لاغاثه الفلسطينيين في غزه ومنح اطفالها
فرصه في الحياه بوتين يضع خطط جديده وطيس
المعارك مستعر في اوكرانيا على غرار ما
يحدث في فلسطين هنا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تعلن تكبيد الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من
1175 قتيلا وجريحا واسقط مروحيه ام اي 8
و34 مسيره اطلقتها قوات كيف على مختلف
المحاور والعهده على المصدر كما نتصفح في
الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه بعيدا عن
اوكرانيا وصل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الى العاصمه الصينيه بيكين للمشاركه
في المنتدى الدولي حزام واحد طريق واحد ال
يصبح طريق روسيا والصين واحدا من اليوم
فصاعدا وما الذي اتفق عليه بوتين مع نظيره
شيجن على الطاوله في الطريق الروسي الجديد
تظهر اليابان حيث حلقت حامل صواريخ
استراتيجيتين روسيتان ان طراز 295 ام اس
فوق بحر اليابان في رحله استغرقت سبع
ساعات وقال قائد فرقه الطيران بعيد المدى
سيرجي كوبيلا تم تنفيذ الرحله بما يتوافق
مع الالتزام الصارم بالقواعد الدوليه
لاستخدام المجال الجوي هل هناك من رد
ياباني
[موسيقى]
ا